here we are home sweet home  you're Luis I presume how was your trip  this old hag is my neighbor I'm relieved  to see you didn't inherit your uncle's  freakishly oversized head my god did  that withered purple skeleton just speak  who in the cast would be most likely to  cast a spell on you I'd say that he lied  planchette because she's so bewitching  Eli Roth  Eli is like a real-life warlock he does  seem to have magic feathers who in the  cast is the most likely to be a secret  warlock deck well Jack Black you tricks  up my sleeve that you're not aware of  it's true Wow I think it's probably  raising the cost but row here the  cinematographer Yeah right he has long  kind of gray hair and what he did was  magic yeah and that time he ate a baby  oh yeah  did he sped it back out again right it's  Jo well I think we're done with this  interview I can give you the right books  teach you the right spells but that last  1% that's up to you  you  you